♪ This is Tea with GaryVee
sipping instantly ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ put enough on my ship for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Michael made flick. ♪
- What's good to you fam?"
It's me Gary, good morning.
It is May 13th.
We are fully in it at this point.
In the COVID crisis (laughs).
Everyone's talking about the new norm,
you mean norm.
Hope everybody's super well.
Let me give some shout
outs before we get into it.
Dustin how are you ?
- Excellent.
- Showered (laughs),
first shower in two days.
So I feel good (laughs).
- That's your normal routine
based on what I remember.
- Yeah didn't mean I hate doing that,
but now it is, now it's normal.
- I got it.
Awesome. Courtney Lord,
what's good Shanoh?
What's good Kim?
Good to see you.
Strategy goddess thank you
so much for being here.
Real estate BJ great
thank you for being here.
Hakim Draper what's good on the
West Coast at 6:00 a.m. life
Big shout out to the twitch fam,
Rosa for health, James oh good to see you.
Darren F Thank You.
Casey, Carrie Gardner
let's get into the show.
- What's good Clev?
- What's good brother? How you doin?
- I'm well.
- I'm showered up bro.
I'm feeling good it's early for me man.
- In West Coast it is.
- East Coast, Southeast.
- So the 9 a.m. is early?
- Yeah it's still early yeah.
- You go to bed at 2:00, 3:00, 4:00 a.m.
- Something like that yeah yeah for sure.
- Yeah man.
How's the music going?
- Good good good.
I just signed with
Republic about a month ago.
I got some records coming out with Diplo,
and Post Malone.
And some big shit coming.
- Congratulations.
- Gonna be a...
Thank you bro thank you.
- How do you feel right now.
I know you're sitting on those tracks,
and you're no dope like you know
that that's gonna give
you a bunch of looks
like do you think like
damn this "might be it."
And are you also mentally prepared?
Because people have done
things with huge artists,
and sometimes it's not the moment,
and it sometimes happens four years later.
Are you in the mindset
of like I'm ready for
if it pops off
or I'm ready for it to
be a disappointment,
and then it will happen in a couple years.
Like are you in that mindset?
- No you know I think I'm
ready for it to pop off.
You know I know that even if it doesn't
like it completely explode over time
it's gonna get me enough looks you know,
I mean that's that's worth it.
I was actually watching a video of yours
on Instagram the other day that was like
one is greater than zero.
And it was really motivating
as far as you know
just taking the little
views you know to me.
- I love that video too for me personally,
because that's the one
that shows even right now,
I've unlimited videos on YouTube
that have 137, 219, 400 too.
And I tell people all
the time like do shit.
Like people like value
their time a lot of times
when it's not valuable,
and so like putting in the work.
- Oh yeah for sure.
But I mean you know you got
a song with Post Malone.
It's really not gonna be that
much of a disappointment,
if it doesn't blow up.
It's still gonna blow up
in a sense you know right.
- And other artists are gonna take a look,
and other producers are gonna take a look,
and other people gonna take a look.
- Right he's just so huge that it's
like you know it's a big opportunity.
I'm really ready to get my album underway,
and really you know kind of
push my stuff in a big way.
But we got some features that you know
during this quarantine
downtime stuff like that.
I think it really kind of keeps me fueled
that you know I mean there's
some big, big views coming.
You know what I mean.
- And I can't wait to see it happen.
What can I answer for you?
- Well you know I get asked
a lot as upcoming artists,
and I'm not where I want to be yet.
But I still get a lot of aspiring artists
that come to me asking
for advice on you know
how to make it in music
you know in general
or they'll say how did you
get this Post Malone feature?
How did you meet Juice Wrld, blase Bob?
But you know I think a lot of it is...
I would like to know
I guess a good response from you,
your side of it.
Maybe using some music based examples.
Just how we would go about responding
to an upcoming artist that's aspiring
to be you know killing it
in entertainment industry.
- For me two things stand out.
Taking it and having it come to you.
So taking it is literally
commenting,
DMing on the biggest
producers and artists,
and you know world stars and a.k.
Just complex distribution places,
but not doing what I see
all the thirsty artists
do which is like leaving a comment on
you know on Ghana's latest post,
or the baby's latest post
or Megan Stein's latest post,
and saying like, "Yo you
got to check out my beats,
"I'm the fucking freshest in the game."
Or like you know, "They sleeping on me,
"I'm the best pretty..."
Like that's just not gonna work.
It's just too thirsty.
But what I do think is when
there's a new you know
key Glock or young boy post,
and you go in there,
and you actually analyze the song.
Or you come out and you you know like
I really really feel Rowdy Rich's lyrics.
So like if you're an artist
or producer that feels it,
and you come in and you quote one line,
and you tell people what you feel there.
Or like you know I listen
to Mozzy's new album
like four times in a row.
And there's just a lot
of things that hit me.
If I was an up-and-coming
artist or a producer,
I would go into those posts,
because he's promoting
the shit out of his joint,
and leave thoughtful thoughtful comments,
not thirsty comments.
So that's going out and taking,
or I DM Mozzy or the producers on that,
or his manager and say, "Yo
that fucking third track
"when he said this..."
Or like you know you just give love
but thoughtful love not spamming,
but actually just genuinely
putting in the work.
So that's going and taking it.
And that may catch someone's attention,
because you know this is an artist Clever,
like you may have a deep lyric
that really means something to you.
It's kind of subtle in a
song nobody gives a fuck,
but if somebody comes around like,
"Yo those nine words together hit me."
You're gonna take note of that.
It's the same way I take note
when people leave a comment my Instagram
about a certain part of a video,
that I can see is not the spiky part,
it's not the part that
everybody caught on,
but I knew what it meant to me,
that catches my attention like,
"Oh that's a thoughtful kid
"let me see what that's going on."
Artists do that too.
That's taking it.
And then having it come to you
is putting out the fucking work.
- Exactly.
- Your music I believe in it.
Like everybody you know
you know this,
you've been watching me for a while,
like I believe that putting
out more music is good,
like I genuinely do.
- Yeah you know I tell
a lot of people like
the content everything that you know
keeping it consistent is great.
a lot of people fail to do the research
that I think that it takes.
You know just digging in,
and trying to you know
find those opportunities
not just you know doing all
the social media things.
But you know a lot of people think
you can just make the record,
and shoot the video,
and put it out there and pray to God,
you know what I mean.
- That's almost a hundred
percent guaranteed to not work,
almost a hundred percent.
- Exactly.
It's hard to explain it to some people,
like they think it's
just gonna catch fire.
And what they have to realize,
there's a lot of the viral videos that
you know it's got a lot
of work going into it.
I know some record
labels that put millions
millions of dollars into
some marketing schemes
for certain artists to get
certain songs at you know
at the number one spot.
- Yeah. If you look at
the top fifty right now,
and you map it to TikTok.
This is why I've been fuckin
yelling at the top of my lungs
for 18 months to every artist,
and every person about TikTok.
Yet if you get you know
I mean there was a moment when
the baby was in my office.
I'm like bro TikTok (laughs).
Like you're already ascending,
but you win in that environment,
and sure enough you
know a couple of quotes
same thing with Little Key
you know like some of the
some of my guys have been
really going in there
like TikTok you know
five TikTok influencers doing a dance
to a certain snippet of a song,
we'll outperform four
million dollar media spend
by a fucking record company
every day of the week in 2020.
- You know and it goes back to your
one is greater than zero thing,
even though even the small influencers.
I noticed when I checked
my stats on Spotify,
you get a lot of a lot of
plays that are you know
a thousand of them only
have a hundred plays,
or fifty plays you know.
But if you're on a
hundred thousand playlist,
and those a hundred thousand playlist
all had a hundred plays on them,
that's a lot of fucking plays man.
- I believe in that shit,
and by the way that's exactly right.
And inevitably you've
got one important person
that's digging deeper and
is on those small playlists,
and that becomes the moment.
- Exactly that one person.
You know it's a lot about who's listening,
and not how meanings sometimes.
Cause you know there was
a couple of people trying
to stop me from doing a particular song.
And that particular song
that came out you know
was something that I
was felt strongly about,
and although people didn't
necessarily feel great
about the song you know enough to push it,
and put a bunch of money behind it.
It just happened to be
a song that got noticed
by Justin Bieber, by Post Malone
that ended up being a feature
that came out the next year.
You know what I mean that it just kind
of keep that consistency going you know.
- It's the single thing
I believe in the most.
Which is when you make the
content you want to make
versus the content that
people want you to make,
or that it looks like
you should be making,
it's literally the post I
post at 8:30 this morning
on Instagram.
It's me and Murda Beatz you know.
And and it's me a year ago
telling him like, "Yo TikTok,"
and he's like, "Yeah but I don't dance."
I'm like, "No no no you do what you do."
And here we are a year later,
and TikTok looks completely different
than it did a year ago.
When I was yelling 18
months ago, a year ago.
Everyone's like,
"Fourteen-year-old girls,"
and I was like, "For now.".
- Right yeah it's definitely huge.
My TikTok is is slacking (laughs).
- I'm telling you right now
I believe that TikTok is more
important to you than Spotify.
How about that?
Not the bullshit.
- Well and you might be right.
I tend to go really hard on
some of the platforms that pay,
because I do so much to
the free stuff that...
- But bro, but bro.
You too smart for that.
Cause you're super thoughtful.
I'm loving this convo.
The number one thing that pays
is the place where
everybody's eyeballs are at,
even though it's not paying you.
Because those eyeballs pay later.
- Right facts that's
that's huge facts.
You know I've got a
TikTok minds at Clever.
I made it look the part you know.
I've got the blue check going on.
I kind of about 3000 followers,
which is you know...
- Clever listen to me.
Let's make this action-oriented,
cuz I'm gonna jump the next call.
Will chop up in real life, I can't wait.
You need to post two or three times a day,
and TikTok it will change
your game I'm telling you.
- Okay lets see how that goes.
- Go all-in I'm telling you.
- Yeah I'm with it. I'm with it.
- I wish well man. Good to see you.
- You to bro. Thank you so much.
- Got you.
- A lot of fun.
Super smart kid.
I like his thoughtfulness.
Good job Dustin,
I know you were playing
with the mic there.
I thought you did a really good job,
that was challenging.
- Yeah it was tough (laughs).
- I'm proud of you.
- Thank you.
- You welcome. It's good to go.
Lets keep this going.
- Hello Gary.
- Reshad or?
- Reshad.
- Reshad real pleasure.
- It's awesome.
I'm excited to be here.
Real quick, I just want to say thank you
a couple of times here.
Thank you to you first of all,
for the amount of content
that you're just given away for free.
You know so many people
want to charge for the words
coming out of their mouths
so I appreciate that.
And you know that it's very simple,
and you cut through the noise you know.
So right to the point.
- I appreciate the simplicity
it comes so natural to me,
and and I think that we cloud
our heads with so many things
are just our fake perception,
and it stops us.
And so I appreciate it thank you.
- Yeah.
And you know I definitely
want to thank your team,
you know Dustin and Zane
for coordinating things
behind the scenes.
I mean I don't think people
necessarily understand
everything that's going
into producing this,
but you know props to those guys for being
on top of things and coordinating.
- I agree.
I think Dustin's getting too much credit,
and Zane is not getting any of that.
Dustin.
- I agree (laughs).
- You agree right?
- Yeah (laughs).
- Alright, get outta here.
All right.
- So I had a couple of questions that
I think caught the team's attention there
a little while back you know.
They've been trying to get me on
the show for a few days.
My first question is just
from the point of view
I'd like to get your perspective on what
you see as leadership and
their responsibilities
during times of crisis.
And I guess how do we how we recover
from crisis to what your perspective is.
What's the biggest
responsibility they have
- To be compassionate, sympathetic
and empathetic to
everybody but themselves.
That's what I think the responsibility is.
I think true leadership is
when you realize you're
working for all of them,
not the reverse.
And I think it's very clear to me,
when I see good leadership,
and when I see bad leadership.
And so for me great the
responsibility of an actual
leader is to as the going gets tough to
be even more about their
army than themselves,
and so does that leader have the humility,
the patience, the empathy, the compassion,
the sympathy, the kindness
to give fucks about everybody
but themselves.
That takes you know self deprecation.
That takes you know selflessness.
It takes a lot of things,
and so I think that's what
I'm looking for and that's...
And I think a lot of you know to me,
only the ultimate leader
can go all the way there.
Me and my companies for example.
Because for example, a lot of
the leaders of my companies,
I've noticed are worried
about their paycheck.
Are worried about their happiness,
and that's because they're not
at that ultimate leader spot just yet.
And then in other people you see it there
even though they aren't
the ultimate leader,
and then you're like oh
they have the attributes
to be an ultimate leader.
So it's about those things.
So I think the responsibility is to put it
on their shoulders it's on them.
- Yeah for sure.
I agree.
I think it's great, love the perspective.
So moving on from that unrelated question,
you know leadership is a passion of why
I've been loving leadership you know.
I mean leadership is such a
broad kind of term I guess,
but you know I mean
leadership in its form,
and its art in its you
know growing yourself,
growing other people.
I love all these stuff.
And I've recently kind of made the jump
to actually doing something,
and you know it's been in
my heart for a long time
to pursue that and to train,
you know grow something out of that.
And I mean really you know
I'm an infant at this point,
you know having just kind of
kicked off my social platforms
and stuff like that.
And I'm trying to be you
know on TikTok and Instagram
and Facebook and LinkedIn and Twitter,
and I'm about to launch
a website and a podcast.
You know but like we're
four weeks into this,
and I don't want to get overwhelming
that I want to dilute
what I'm trying to do.
And so I just want to know
what you believe would be
the best actions for me
to focus in on.
- I think eliminating the word dilution.
You know volume does not mean dilution.
- Right.
So just keep pumping it out.
- I don't feel diluted.
Saying shit you don't believe is dilution.
- Yeah
I get you.
- But you can say the same thing
across 13 different platforms,
the same exact thing
thirteen different ways.
Cause LinkedIn is different than TikTok,
and that means it's not diluted.
The dilution comes in saying
shit you don't believe,
and you don't know what the
fuck you're talking about.
The dilution does not come
in the volume of creative
that is put out.
- Great.
I get it (laughs).
- Makes sense?
- Makes sense.
- People focus on dilution or quality
in amount of pieces out.
There are some people that are diluted
the first fucking words
out of their mouth,
because they're talking some bullshit.
Doesn't matter if they
only posted one time.
- Yeah I think I end up thinking too hard
about what I'm trying to say
and to try and make really in-depth
in deep long-form content
and stuff like that.
It's just...
You're you know I sit there's
staring at my computer screen
for like you know this is sound good,
this does not sound good.
- It's even in the way
you're you're doing this QA
with me it makes sense to me right.
Like I think you put
thoughtfulness on a pedestal
which is amazing.
But I think that if you're
thoughtful it will come out,
you know.
I think a lot of people think
too much about presentation,
like I come out like you know
there's a very good chance that
I'll go down as the kindness
entrepreneur of a generation,
yet I don't think that's
how people saw me at first
with my fucking cursing
and aggressiveness,
and competitiveness and Jerseyness.
And so what I mean by that is
the truth will always shine.
It's just the way it is.
There's no hiding it in life.
And so no matter how
clever people try to do,
or how much they package it,
you know it's just so obvious to me
that you know it will
all ultimately play out,
no matter how misunderstood
I was for a decade.
A lot of it is starting to play out.
Heck! I think this show
has a lot to do with it.
And yet you know, I couldn't
have predicted COVID
or you know I kind of
predicted Tea with GaryVee.
The song on that clip from
10 years ago on Instagram,
but you know
I definitely feel as though
you're overthinking it,
because if you've got it,
it will play out.
And if you don't it will play out.
And I think you try to package it you know
is not going to be the variable.
- Right
- That's it.
- Yeah pretty thoughtful you know...
- You should be thoughtful by nature,
not by sitting there and
be tactically thoughtful.
Don't become a fucking poet you know,
like fucking just put it
out however it comes out.
The more you put it out.
I'm better at putting it
out than I was a decade ago.
I've kept putting it out putting it out,
and then it gets refined.
It doesn't get refined in your head,
it gets refined by living it.
- I get it.
- Good.
- Thank you.
I want to see you in Hamilton.
I got that like on my
ticket I hope that...
- I'm desperately trying to get there.
One time canceled,
the second time in the fall.
I'm worried about we'll see what happens,
but I will get my ass to Hamilton.
I'm committed.
See you soon. Take care.
- Take care. Thank you.
- Right. I love this.
Swing for the ring good to see you.
Stephen Potter great to see you.
- Wanted to hear your
thoughts on something.
- Please.
- On YouTube there's someone
that's kind of spamming,
and yet and everyone's
telling me to ban him,
but I'm not gonna.
Because it's obviously not my call.
- Yeah look I think you know,
I saw it on twitch a little bit.
I'm seeing on a YouTube a little bit,
like I think we're gonna
need to consider mods.
You know everybody's kind
of looking right now.
Dustin not Justin is your
Instagram handle right?
- Yeah.
- Maybe.
And let's not over flood Dustin,
if you genuinely want to be a mod,
meaning you want to be here every day.
You feel like you understand me,
which is don't ban too early.
I like when people razz me.
It's just when somebody just spams.
- I mean that's what it is.
It's not someone
harassing me. It's just...
- Yeah I know that's what you're saying,
but you may need to need to some mods,
so we'll talk about that.
- Okay.
- Is he already still doing it?
- No I try I asked him nicely,
if you could just cut it
like try to stop a little bit.
And he said (laughs).
He pretty much told me
to fuck off (laughs).
- It's fine.
It's fine.
Lets put him on the show.
Let me have convo.
- Okay.
- Hello my friend.
- Most adverse I call.
- Hello.
- I can hear you what's your name?
- Okay thank you.
My name is Moaaz Terkawi.
I'm in the Iraq University.
I'm 18 years old.
I have two question for you.
Hope you can distribute your thought on.
The first one is I like you in a speech,
and how you communicate with people,
and be effective with new speech.
I do mention about how
the voice technology
will make them better in the future.
So thank you.
Through the value that you've put there.
And now it's talking in front
of all that big audience,
what makes your anxiety or makes you...
What fire bucks say.
And how you arrange the topics
that you want talking about,
what's the steps do you
take before the evening?
Because when I see you on their evenings.
I saw you're working in your from...
I kind of think gonna happen what's
what's make you uncomfortable
from the inside.
I'd let you focus on
what you're about to say.
- So I think the question is
when I'm communicating you know,
how am I able to gather my thoughts,
so I know what I'm talking about on stage.
How do I make that transition.
What's my process to know what I want
to be communicating
about in that scenario,
whether it's on stage or somewhere else.
Is that right Moaaz?
- Yes. How do you focus?
What makes you comfortable
on the inside that you focus?
- Understood.
To that point,
and you went even more
thoughtful, I appreciate that.
What is it in me that allows
me to be so comfortable,
confident and and then quiet and focused,
that it lets me articulate
at the level that I do.
- Exactly.
- This is a very fun moment for me.
I think it comes down to experience,
experience.
I think a lot of people
want to speak early on,
and things that nature.
The number one reason I'm able to...
There's many things I have natural improv
in comedic improv capabilities.
I'm very comfortable in all scenarios.
I have an amazing
relationship with adversity,
and tough situations.
So going on stages as tough as
it gets for a lot of people,
but I'm okay if it doesn't go well.
I also think experience,
so it's an experience and adversity.
My relationship with adversity I'm okay
with anything happening.
The mic doesn't work,
people boo me.
They think it's stupid.
It's all fine for me that
relationship with that adversity.
Number two, I only talk about what I know.
Too many people talk about
things they don't know.
Too many people want to talk about things
that they haven't lived yet,
that they haven't experienced,
that they're not experts in.
They talk about it because
it's the cool thing,
or a hot thing or the important thing.
They talk about shit they don't know.
It's not the truth.
So I speak my truth,
and I have a relationship
with that adversity,
which means on a moment's notice.
Moaaz if you were like,
"Hey Gary, my screen's
now gonna turn to five hundred
thousand people in Iraq,
and I need you to give a keynote.
I would do it right now.
Right now.
I would say Tea I'm sorry,
I have to give this half
a million person keynote.
My friends and family and I...
You know like I would go right into it.
so I think it's about staying in my lane,
only talking about what I know,
and being unbelievably
comfortable with adversity.
- That's what you do believe in thought?
- A hundred percent.
I believe in myself because I don't care
what people think about me.
It's my relationship with judgment.
I don't care.
And what I mean by that,
of course I care I'm a human being.
But I can't value it more
than my own happiness.
I can't live on somebody else's terms.
I can't.
It's a bad idea.
- How to make the balance
between your opinions
and the data that you have.
Have you outspoken it before?
- Data shows you yesterday,
my intuition helps me with tomorrow.
I respect data but only after the fact.
There is no data of the future,
and I only play in the future.
I only play what's in
front of me work tomorrow.
Right now and tomorrow.
Yesterday's yesterday.
There is no dwelling.
There is no you know what was me,
there is no oh that's how it was.
I take the past and I context it.
The past is what told me
TikTok was gonna be important,
because I watched.
I've experienced on how Vine, how Twitter,
how Instagram, how Snapchat happened.
So I saw the patterns.
I saw the patterns.
So I respect the past,
but I don't over dwell on it.
And when somebody says
to me, "Well Gary 86% of
"people buy their products
at stores not on e-commerce
"in America."
I'm like, "Yes that was
yesterday now we have COVID,
"things are gonna change." Dah dah dah.
So it's that balance.
I appreciate my friend I wish you well.
Thank you for being on the show.
- Okay.
Just next second is.
I worked up about three years in a Iraq's
Horse company called kurdsale.com
that run by my uncle and my dad.
My work is in this company
is Horse photographer.
I just want you to see my work in this.
My stuff.
- Please.
- I didn't document the
entire process in my working,
but I was some example in my profile.
So hope you can see it.
- A hundred percent.
- Can you see it now?
- Of course.
I will take a look at it.
I'll have Dustin set me up.
All right?
- Okay.
I worked in this company to
is car specifications and
I have a powerful knowledge
about the car specification,
and I worked a supervisor
at our work with part
and cars in Houston,
and I worked there as a website admin.
What I worked in my spare time is
I learnt multiple things like
video editing and programming,
but I didn't achieve the
level of professionalism,
as I think.
Because I spent my time in it as hobby.
- That make sense.
Plus you're a kid.
You were 15 to 18.
- Yeah.
- You're a fucking kid.
That's why.
- Thank you a lot.
- I'll save you time on the answer,
you know kid.
- Thanks a lot.
- You're welcome.
- I watch a lot of this video.
I investigate and listen on just
how the business world,
my interest is in marketing and branding.
Maybe in the future go to businesses.
- I'd love that man.
We'll get to know each other.
- Now what's the requirements?
Maybe I can work in your company.
I've been looking forward
to working with you
for a long time.
I was so happy.
Anything that brought me
in the marketing field.
- Listen...
- Yeah I got it.
I appreciate you taking a shot.
Good news for you.
- Any requirements that you require?
- Yep. Good news for you.
- Working for free.
I'm going to take very first as time,
working here on on your quartering.
Even if you want to let
me train in the beginning.
I show you my Google feeds.
Because my goal is to learn.
- I appreciate it.
I appreciate it.
Listen to me.
Good news.
Now that we're more open to remote work,
we may have a shot.
I'm gonna have Dustin
connect us after this,
and we'll get to talking next week or two.
Okay?
- Yes.
- All right good luck brother.
Let's get it going.
- Thank you.
- Thanks for all of you who are watching,
bearing with it cause obviously
the audio was a little tough.
But I just liked him,
and wanted to get through that.
So let's keep it going.
Moe.
- Hey Gary what's up?
- Life is good brother,
how are you?
- I'm doing fine.
I want to thank you a lot for
this amazing program that you're doing.
Like I've learned so much.
It's the best shit on the internet really.
- Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Where are you from brother?
- Thank you.
I'm originally from Lebanon,
but I'm currently in Denmark,
like I've been living in
Europe for the past five years.
And I think it helped me a
lot in many aspects a lot.
- I love it.
- Yeah.
I'm just gonna give you a small backstory,
and then you know you can
help me a bit better I think.
So
I came from Lebanon,
and I studied in Poland.
I studied medicine,
and I finished my
medical degree this year.
And the thing with medicine is like
you know like it's a
very demanding profession
especially in residency
you need so much work,
you need to work like really long hours.
And it's very difficult you know.
And I want this thing,
where I want to really empower others
especially young people,
because I've been there.
I've been in this third-world country,
and I know how difficult it is actually
to go outside that community you know,
and how to find that opportunity outside.
So I just want to help like people,
because I had this scholarship back there.
So I want to help like more
people have more opportunities
to just do the things that they want.
- How would you do that?
- Like I think by the you know like there
is many ways to do it.
- I agree.
- A big factor can be like financially,
it can be very helpful like helping them
getting the education that they want.
Supplying them with a jobs that
they can get some valuable
knowledge in you know.
Like many many stuff you know like
I see people out there,
and they are like studying for long years,
and there is no jobs and a market
for what they have studied.
- Yes, because the modern
education system globally
has some substantial flaws in it
compared to what the people think
they're getting out of that education.
The promise of the 1950s,
'60s, '70s and '80s,
even '90s of like if you go to university,
or if you go to you know to your point.
Even some of the things
that are still safe,
legal and medical things that nature.
Like it's a very different world
out there with the internet.
The promises that have
been made for generations
are vulnerable right now.
Obviously there's still plenty of careers,
where if you get that degree
that is the only way to get in,
but people are massing
enormous amounts of debt.
The amount of money that
they're getting in return
is not where it used to be
especially in the medical field
and other places.
And yes I agree there's
major vulnerabilities
with the system.
- Yeah I agree too.
So this leads me to my question.
Which is like how can I Gary
like balance my career as a doctor,
and my passion to empower others
given like the very demanding
profession you know,
like it yet you need
some time to help others.
And how can you make up that time.
- By auditing all your leisure.
- Can you please explain me.
- Of course.
I want to know every hour of your life,
when you're not doing your medical field,
and you're not sleeping.
I'd like to understand every hour.
- I understand.
But the problem is...
- Go ahead.
- I understand it's like working,
like I haven't started working yet,
but I'm gonna start working in a month.
- Okay.
- And I've done some internships.
So I've seen exactly what's the work like.
Like an internship for
like a month and a half,
I've lived it.
- I understand.
- It's like very demanding job you start
working at 7:30 in the morning,
and you finish work by 5:00 or 6:00.
You're completely exhausted,
you need to go and eat something.
And really tired,
and you end up sleeping
and waking up at 6:00 in the morning.
On the weekends you will have shifts,
maybe every two weekends,
you will have like a weekend off.
But that's mostly it.
- Yeah so a couple things.
I've always wanted to help people too.
And in the beginning of
my career I didn't do it,
because the internet wasn't at scale.
And I was working retail you know
six or seven days of the week you know.
And I was working much longer hours
than you're referring to you know.
I would get to the store at 7:30, 8:00,
then open at 9:00.
I would work until it
was closed at 9:00 p.m.
And then I would go home.
And so I very much understand...
I would work 9:00 to 10:00
p.m. on Friday and Saturday.
Every single day for seven, eight years.
So maybe the answer to your question is
you can help people in
seven years not today.
When I talk about patience,
I really talk about patience.
If you're telling me that your job
is gonna milk you so hard.
And require you not to
have the energy to help.
Well then you don't
Now it's just now it's just ideolody
ideology excuse me.
Now you're just saying
you know you'd like to which is fine.
I just don't think you have to you know
beat yourself up that
you're not doing it yet,
maybe you can do it in five years.
- Like the thing is like
I've seen like many people,
and in some way they are able to do it
like I'm sure you have
like so much work to do
so many things to do,
but still you can find.
- Because I don't fear messing up.
- Okay.
- The reason most people
are able to do more
is because they don't lack,
they don't fear losing.
They don't fear failure.
People that fear failure don't do things.
The reason I'm so fast is
I don't put perfection on a pedestal.
80% of something done is better
than 0% of something done.
If you help one person by
doing a one-hour Skype.
When you said you still
have two to three months,
I laughed in my head.
I literally laughed.
Cause I said, "Okay great
yeah so fucking help people
"for next two to three months,
"you could be on the fucking
Internet twelve hours a day."
- I've started.
I started. Actually I did
like an Instagram feed on
certain things that will
help like young people.
- It's good.
- Yeah.
And I'm doing it already,
because few already like it.
- And because of you.
- I said probably to just start.
- More.
More.
- It is very important.
- More.
- Yeah, yeah. I think so.
I think I will just need to put more.
- More. More.
You know some days you're gonna
feel energized after work,
and from 9:00 to 11:00 p.m.
you're gonna lay in bed,
and make content and
answer somebody's question.
And you know DM somebody
to be on their podcast,
because you know you have
that weekend off in two weeks.
This is a very simple game.
Is that you're doing it or you're not.
Either you're doing it in real life,
or you're doing it in your head.
And in real life it works better.
- That's true. Yeah.
- Awesome. Take care my brother.
- And that's why I like your content,
because it's practicality.
Thank you very much bro.
- You're welcome brother, thank you.
- It is practicality like
it's actions over everything.
The reason I get into mindset,
and some bigger issues is
because they're the seeds
that don't lead to action.
Let's keep going.
- Dude ah! (laughs).
- How are you?
- Yo Gary good man thanks.
How are you?
- Good man. What's your name?
- My name's Kris Cacciotti
from Sudbury Ontario, Canada.
- It's a pleasure Kris.
Between the five hat and the work hard,
like I'm feeling you're ready.
- Right yo Gary this this hat
is the local Sudbury
professional basketball team.
This Sudbury Five.
- I've got it.
- I obviously had...
- I've got to get one.
- (laughs) Obviously I had to wear.
I'll send you one.
- I appreciate it.
- And there's a story that you told about,
fascinated by it where you
went to the Knicks game
with the ugly sweater and sat court side.
And that kind of had a whole
bunch of attention on you,
and on the jumbotron.
And I kind of applied that.
- Sports center.
- Yeah Sports Center.
When I go to basketball
games I have sat court side
for the inaugural season last year.
Well season tickets on the court,
and I wore this like fuzzy flannely
kind of colorful jacket with red pants,
that the whole stadium can see.
And I became like a super fan almost so.
That was built on the back
of that story that you told
with the Knicks ugly sweater.
- I appreciate it Kris.
What can I do.
- Yeah. So first off I want to start off.
I know you don't hear compliments,
but I know that you're
very interested in legacy.
So I just want to thank
you from the bottom
of my heart for all of the guidance
that you've been giving me from afar
for the last five years.
I mean it's
you drive home so many important concepts,
and you've really changed the way
I think about a lot of things.
And its really had a
massive impact on my life,
and you're actually changing
the course of humanity.
I believe with by making
things like patience,
and gratitude.
Patience, gratitude,
handwork, empathy, kindness
you're making these cool.
And your impact not only my generation,
but younger generations,
the older generations.
You're impacting the entire planet,
and you are gonna reach your
goal of everyone on earth
knowing who you are and when they do,
you're gonna make the
world a much better place.
So I just wanted to start off with that.
- Thank you brother.
- What you can help me with is,
I work for the YMCA of
Northeastern Ontario.
So in the not-for-profit sector,
and I got there by after
9 years in the private
construction industry worked my way up
from site superintendent up
to a junior partnership offer,
but it just wasn't
lighting my soul on fire,
wasn't making me happy.
I wasn't really passionate about it.
- Yeah.
- But it was making good money,
and I had an opportunity
to make a lot of money
for my family and provide for my family.
So I kind of grinded it out.
- I respect that too.
- But in 2017 our son
was diagnosed in utero
with a really insane and
critical heart disease.
- I'm sorry to hear that.
- Thank you.
And he had open heart surgery at birth,
and during the recovery process,
and kind of taking all
this into consideration.
I just came to the realization that life
is just far too short to be spending it
doing something that you don't love.
I jumped in with the Y,
and now I feel like I've
really found my links.
I get to use my talent
skills and passions,
and everything that
makes me me is an asset,
and a strength and I get to deploy that
to make the community that
I live in a better place.
- I love you for that.
- Thank you.
- So the long winded way
to get into this question
is how do I apply the 5149 rule,
or giving more than I take
into fundraising whereby
the main function of my role
is to get is to depend on
other people's generosity,
when those people are
not the the benefactors
of that generosity?
- By asking them what you
can bring to the table.
Hey old rich dude in neighborhood,
who can actually afford to pay a check
that will help the YMCA even though none
of his family or people
he knows are there,
what can I Kris in any shape or form
bring you in value.
I'm not kidding.
That's actually the answer.
I think fundraising are real...
I think it's one of the most
interesting moves of fundraising.
Instead of doing what most people do,
which is try to guilt
or play towards one's bleeding heart.
I think the question is
what can I do for you?
you'd be shocked I mean I've seen
I've seen things cause I'm
quiet with what my fundraising,
but I'm on a lot of boards,
I do a lot of stuff.
And it's wild what some
of the answers are.
Like sometimes the answer looks like,
my daughter's struggling with swimming,
and you or your best friend happens
to be a great fuckin swimmer,
and it's literal I'm not kidding,
it's literally checked
to YMCA your best friend
is teaching his or her daughter to swim.
- Right, okay. So right okay.
So it basically boils
down to understanding
the people you are
approaching to be donors.
- By asking them what you could bring
to them in value.
You don't even need to understand.
I don't even understand shit.
I can walk up to Sir Winston Thompson, and
be like, "Hello Sir Winston Thompson what
"is the most interesting things to happen
"in your world."
The most interesting
the reason I'm sitting here luckily
our friend Karen put us together is
I want you to write a check to the YMCA,
cause I'm passionate here's my story.
My son's heart condition dah dah.
That already puts you in a good spot.
I'm here not looking
for you to write a check
out of the goodness of your heart,
because I want to make this practical.
What on earth can I help you with?
I'm a social butterfly,
I'm connected to a lot of people.
I have a lot of my own skills.
I will believe for you in
return for what you want,
because I want you not even for me.
I want you to give that money to the YMCA,
that is a fucking killer pitch.
- Yeah that is a killer pitch.
Right okay.
- The end.
- Kris, the end.
- Approach people ask them what they want,
or approach people ask
them what they want and...
- And obviously, and obviously
the way that you approach it.
Your success rate will be on your cadence,
will be on your skillset in asking.
Some people are gonna be dopey about it.
Some people gonna walk
up to somebody be like,
"Yo what do you want?"
And it's like they're like scared,
like you know like you
have to find your cadence
your tact, your ability.
But it is the punchline
of the question period.
It will outperform every
other way you go about it.
It would work on me.
I don't want to see your fucking picture
of the fucking playground
you're gonna build
with my money.
I don't care about the
cute picture of the kids.
Of course I do, that is a given.
I understand that to be true.
It's not that I don't care,
and I'm heartless it's
that I know what the fuck
you're up to.
The YMCA is super branded.
I get it.
If you come at me with
what do you want from me?
I'm like, "Wow you know that's powerful."
- Right cause no one's really
it doesn't seem like in
the fundraising world,
that a lot of people are
taking that approach.
- They're not at all.
I tell my non-profit friends
all the time you're audacious.
Just because somebody has money,
why the fuck should they give it to you?
My brother has Crohn's disease.
I want to give that money to that.
I have fucking...
I got highest the
foundation to help my family
get out of Russia.
I want to give to that.
Like why am I you know what you know
people want to give to
things that they care about
not what you care about.
- Right. So then a way to
kind of sweeten the deal
is on top of the altruistic nature
of it what's in it for me basically.
- 100%
- What can I do for you?
- Yep.
And if you end up fucking,
you know shoveling snow (laughs).
- That's it.
Way to go. I would shovel
the snow, I would do that.
- Me too. Me too.
- Life's about value exchange,
and too many people look at the people
that are in a position to give.
And they just think that they should give.
It lacks complete empathy,
it lacks any kind of kindness.
It's a completely audacious.
It's an unbelievable as if
it's just not fair you don't
know anything about them.
You don't know how they made their money.
You don't know what
they're doing currently.
You don't know their actual situation.
People just fucking
think that they should,
as if like hey why aren't
you doing this Sir Winston,
writing a $10,000 check is easy for you,
you don't know.
- Right yeah exactly.
- You don't know shit.
So ask for what you can
bring to the table period,
end of story.
Guilt and expectations don't work.
- No I'm not I'm not into that.
I'm not into guilt.
I'm not into playing the victim
in any way, in any way shape
or form I mean that's one of
the major kind of mindsets
that I have, and again based on a lot
the two major themes that you
that you preach accountability
accountability and gratitude is that
accountability plus gratitude is a choice.
A choice to say when you're presented with
a difficult decision you have a choice
to either crumble use it as an excuse,
and kind of break down.
Or order to push through
develop as a human,
and actually come out on the other side.
- Kris ask people what you
could do for them, the end.
- Yeah okay sweet.
One more thing, one more thing.
In January I launched a children's book.
I wrote a children's book 10%
of its going to sick kids.
I actually sent one to your
office a couple months ago,
I don't know if it made its way to...
I don't know if it made its
way to Misha and Xander,
- I appreciate it brother.
I'll ask Lu and Alex I'm
sure they're watching
or Dustin will let them know.
I'll look for it.
What's the name of it?
- It's called my very excellent mother
just served us nine pizzas.
(Gary laughs)
Yeah it's a pseudonym for how we learn,
how to memorize the names that
the order of the planets growing up,
when you're in school.
- I love that.
- But checking in on
that wasn't the reason
for this question is actually
tactical question on.
I just basically the way I've
been marketing these books
is like guerrilla marketing
on my personal page.
I've sold like 700 units,
pushing 800 units.
I'm getting consignment deals.
I'm getting like corporate buyers,
who buy in big bulk numbers.
- Do you have a Facebook group?
- I don't have a Facebook group.
No I started a Facebook page,
but I've been slacking on getting a going
same thing with Instagram.
- Facebook and Instagram
are your two platforms
for this book.
- Yeah okay.
And what kind of content pillars
do you think independent
publishing co. Could...
- What about you? What about the book?
What about you know the
first fans of the book,
you know just the content.
- Right and I got to say Gary that
a lot of the support that I've gotten
off the initial phases of this book,
have been completely predicated on things
that I've learned from you.
And about like personal branding,
and giving more, and no expectations.
And everything that's been
happening with this book
has basically been built
on kind of the model
that you've been preaching since
I've started listening to you.
- That you executed.
I have super admiration brother.
Lots of people listen to me.
Most don't execute.
Keep doing it.
I love you pal talk to you soon.
- I love you too bro. Take care.
- Nice kid.
I like that dude's energy a lot.
All right let's keep it moving.
- Oh shit GaryVee UGK for life all right.
Also hope I get to play you someday.
Anyway dude I just want to put out there
thank you for everything.
I didn't even hear about your ass
until about two months ago.
This conversation has the potential
to change the trajectory of
music education globally I feel.
So I want to just briefly talk about me.
Cause it's not about me,
raised in Missouri, I'm 41.
World champion drummer,
world champion drum instructor.
I breed world champion drummers.
One of my students just
recently played the Emmys.
Later in life in my
30s here comes dubstep,
(Gary laughs)
the producer for like ten years.
Some people would say one of the pioneers
in American dubstep.
Play with Bass nectar pretty lights.
Played in 48 states
festivals coast to coast.
I had a record label
called Al's dope records,
and it's blew up in my face in 2018,
because I ended up over-promising.
Spread myself then.
I ended up getting on at
a corporate music school,
that has a movie and Broadway
musical named after it.
And you know jack box the star,
and they brought me on
as a drum instructor,
then the music director,
then the general manager.
And I was at a franchise so
I real wanted to start
this EDM and DJ program,
like hip-hop EDM production
DJ program for the kids.
So I lined it up been working on it.
I launched it at my franchise in Denver,
and then there's a company school.
I'm originally from Missouri,
so there was a position
open in Kansas City.
I started flying back and
forth every week this year
before COVID.
And I really thought that corporate
was gonna finally bite on it right,
but they're really stuck
on ACDC Nirvana Pearl Jam,
that type of thing.
They're not really you know
I keep getting push back all right.
So here we are
is eight weeks in the COVID.
- Push back in the form of like
this is not real music,
and we love and we love grunge better.
Like on some subjective shit.
- In the form of like yeah, bro.
- I get it.
- I mean so.
- By the way that's most of
what happens in the world.
I just want to make sure I'm grounded,
and what the pushback is.
- Yeah I mean a push back is you know,
I finally thought they were gonna let me
do it this corporate school.
Because I got their attention,
because we had a successful season,
like the program is lit.
It fucking it succeeds bro okay.
- Love it.
- So where I'm at with the bro is you know
I had the conversation with
the software companies,
and let them know what's up, they're down.
And you know I feel
like I keep getting this
well well let's talk
about it in 18 months,
we'll talk about it then.
- Well that's fucking
that's corporate.
- Right exactly right.
- That's what you signed up for bro.
- Well
- Well nothing.
You took it at about an entrepreneurship,
you miss played it.
You're young as fuck still.
You're resetting your corporate,
so you eating up the
fucking fat piece of shit.
And now we're gonna
make some new decisions.
- Yes right so that's why we
launched spankystudio.com.
While still keeping all of
these lessons online right.
Dudes through zoom it's more
like a mental health checkup,
and what I'm realizing is like
doing the music production
on Ableton through zoom
is way more efficient and productive.
Because I can annotate
right there on this screen,
we get work done through zoom.
So I guess really want I'm at Gary
is I'm gonna do this regardless,
I'm here to double down on my strengths.
I know what I do is
gonna happen regardless.
School of Rock, sorry
they didn't holler back.
And I said you know what
if they don't holler back
by the time I get on here with GaryVee,
what's the worst he's gonna say is no.
So GaryVee my question to you is
do you have any interest in helping launch
the school of hip-hop and EDM?
- Probably no, but not for a bad reason.
Like I really believe in it.
And I genuinely believe
just on your energy
that it's gonna work.
My biggest thing right now
is my liquid situation,
because I've got to save my own businesses
in a global pandemic.
It's not where I want it to be.
So I'm super head down.
Plus my stopgap, kind
of my insurance policy
I always have my personal
brand speaking career,
and that's gone from something significant
to dead fucking zero.
And then it goes into savings lands.
So the timing.
I'm just not in that spot right now.
- Yeah yeah I feel that.
- But but you know I think that
if you want to email
me at Garyvaynermedia.
What you think financially it
needs to get off the ground,
I'm happy to populate it a little bit,
because I have a ton of friends in music,
who might find it more passionate
and more compelling.
Cause I can tell you right now
the energy is there.
The question is what did you
learn from the over-promising
under-delivering and
your cash flow management
on the record label?
However record labels
are much more high-risk
high-reward than a school,
where you're getting
revenue in it every time.
So I'm happy to look at that,
and I don't need a fucking business plan.
I need fucking six sentences
that tell me what the fuck you're up to.
- Alright yo bro.
You are my Russian Jesus.
(Gary laughs)
- I got you Kevin.
I wish you well. Take care.
Let's get one more in here Dust.
- Hi Melissa you're on mute.
- Hey Gary.
- Hi Melissa.
- I didn't think I was gonna get on.
I'm so excited.
- I'm glad we made it happen.
- I'm very grateful to be here,
and I echo your team's
been really awesome,
amazing customer service.
- Thank you.
- (Sighs loudly) So my question to you,
and if you want context
I can give it to you.
But when do you decide
to give up a project,
or a side hustle.
- When you decide to.
Look there have been people
that have given up on a project
and a side hustle literally one month
before it was gonna pop.
The amount of people
that you know were meant
to be "music famous"
but gave up at it at 27.
When their next song was gonna be
what was gonna make them hit.
And now they're an
accountant I believe in that.
But I believe that
percentage is much smaller,
much smaller call that the 1% to the 99%
that are delusional and tone-deaf
to the response of the market.
And are still grinding at something that
the world has told them
they're not good at.
- Yeah so I have a protein
bar called it Fits Bar.
It's down here.
And it launched awesome
in 2017, it was great.
And then I had all of
these manufacturing issues,
so I lost customers.
I lost all my store you know things
got super tough and crazy.
And then in 2018 I have a
disease called endometriosis
kind of like Crohn's like
what you're saying with your brother.
And I had had this big surgery,
and I remember like laying in
bed like in the hospital bed,
like being on Instagram for the brand.
And I was like you know this is like
I have to change this.
So I stepped back and found
a different manufacturer,
which has been great and their local,
I'm in Detroit.
They're local here in Detroit.
Yeah much love back.
- Yeah and that story's
gonna resonate right,
like let there be no
confusion post this pandemic
like made in America is
gonna have a real surge.
People are gonna like...
The one time people will pay more
is when they want to feel safer.
And and that will happen.
That just is gonna happen
for at least half the audience of America.
So keep going.
- Yeah I hope so.
So I take the step back.
I haven't really been
like pushing anything
on that social Channel.
And in this time like
I suffer from this chronic illness.
And I'm like I got to
start to go in on all this.
There's no awareness on this.
I'm super passionate about it right,
and so I start this podcast that
is doing actually really well.
I've been doing it for two years.
So like my focus a little bit shifted,
but now I'm ready to
relaunch the protein bar.
And I'm just like in the pandemic,
and like all of this now my day gig,
which is in marketing and e-commerce,
which you know all about is a 24/7 job.
Unfortunately mine is not going
to be going forward after this
coronavirus stuff.
And that's what's been
funding all of these
kind of hobbies is what
I like to call them.
I'm kind of at this crossroads,
like I don't want to give
up on the protein bar.
But I've never made a dime on it,
and should I give up on it.
But I think it potentially has legs.
- Probably not.
Even the way you're talking about it,
it has too much happiness attached to it.
I think the bigger question
is now the practice
so the emotional part I would say no.
Like listening to you the
answers my can take no.
Now we need to layer the practical part.
If you're losing money on this,
and you can't afford to lose money,
you might just need to take a pause.
And then the question
becomes can you make money?
Like can it become a moneymaker?
Like for example you know yeah you know
you got a local producer of it now.
I'm sure the costs are
a little bit higher,
but you've got the
stability of it you know.
Are you able to charge more?
Or will customers push back?
Because 30 million are out of their jobs,
and like fuck you with
the protein bar twice
as expensive as everything else well.
- Well when I first
launched it someone said,
"There's a thousand protein
bars at Whole Foods,
"why would you do that?"
And that almost like
that's the old me to yeah...
- Fuck that.
There's nothing that is invented.
Whoever that friend or
relative or co-worker,
or family member is needs
to get punched in the face.
- I was like but the competitive price
like what you were saying with price,
like that's like I have
to be in a certain range.
- What if you innovate?
What if your protein bar that
anybody that buys a 12-pack
gets part of a closed zoom group
and all of you get together once a month,
and now all of a sudden
your protein bar is $6,
instead of a dollar.
How much are protein bars?
- I mean under $2.99 is probably really
where you want to be.
- All right got it.
So what if yours was actually $5.99,
when you buy a 24...
How much is it in a case? 12, 24?
- 12.
- 12. What if yours was
$5.99 for a 12-pack,
but you get a code inside of the box,
when you buy it in a 12-pack only.
You only sell them in 12 packs,
we're innovating now.
Is what I do well.
- Yeah yeah.
- When you get it you get a unique code
that gets you confirmation
to get into a group,
that gets to talk for
what if you mix both of your worlds,
what if this is actually
targeted towards females.
And you see what I ...
- Yeah. I made it because I
struggle with certain foods,
so it's dairy and gluten free.
- So why don't why you
become the first person
that makes it a content access bar,
not just the bar.
So now the bar is 72 bucks a case.
Now you're making a couple bucks,
and now you're sitting in a closed zoom,
or Google hangout each
twice a month for three
hours building community.
- And maybe providing some sort of value
or content based on like my knowledge
for what I know.
- The value is you're the Pied Piper,
you're throwing the tea party virtually
like now all these women
are gonna have a community.
You guys are gonna be
friends that's the value.
You're the orchestrator.
You're a conductor of this
fucking incredible community
that is clearly gonna be epic,
if people are buying a
$72 case of protein bar,
just to be
it's gonna be the community part
that they're actually buying.
It's a fucking good idea.
I want you to do this.
- I want this is what I want.
I mean I have to still find a date with...
- You know what still this latter is
I just fucking gave you
a real business idea.
- I've been thinking like
I have this successful
should the bar sponsor the podcast,
like I've been thinking about that.
- Well good news.
I'm better at business than you.
I've learned something better on the spot,
here you go.
here we go.
You're you now sell it direct
for 72 bucks a case only.
You can't buy what...
It's only I only sell it
fuck third party places.
You're the only one that sells it.
It's 72 bucks.
Now you don't even need to come...
Wait a minute now I'm pumped
with you being the only
one who's selling it.
Fuck the little code you've
got all the information,
you just email B look...
your email is now gonna be the email
you just bought this with is now allowed
into this fucking
password-protected community.
I'll see you Friday
nights from 6:00 to 8:00
twice a month can't wait to see you,
You're gonna fucking kill this.
- You think people actually do that?
- I'm convinced.
I'm completely convinced people do.
It's even better than that.
Everybody whose watching right now,
don't just do it to be nice.
If you're actually interested in...
What's your email?
Melisssa@itfitsbar if you want to yeah.
- Melissa.
@itfitsbar. Super easy.
- Right so I'm gonna wait
for Dustin do his thing.
Let's make sure this is the right email.
I'm reading the comments
across all the pieces.
I think there's a lot of
women that would join this.
People like friends.
- There's a...
- This is part of this?
- Yeah yeah yeah wait wait.
Yeah one in ten women have this disease,
like it's very prevalent
in 200 million women.
- Right and so to me if those same women
are paying three bucks for
a protein bar they like.
Now they're paying six dollars,
but for that extra three dollars,
they're gonna be part of a close community
that's gonna become a sisterhood.
Fuckin you know how much
more expensive therapy is?
(Melissa laughs)
Do you know how expensive
a glass of wine is?
When you go out with some
girlfriends to dwell.
It's a fuckin deal.
This might be too cheap.
We may have to make it $99 a 12-pack.
- I love you.
I seriously love you.
- I genuinely think it's a great idea.
I think it's gonna fuckin work.
- I will do this.
And I will tell you
I'll follow up with you.
I will do this is.
- I think is such a big
idea that most people
should follow this.
I think this is a model,
meaning like everybody
right now that has a product
should go to this model.
It's access.
Like if I made empathy forty bucks
but it came with an hour of me.
I would fuckin be ten times bigger.
And an hour with me with
everybody you know what I mean?
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah no I agree.
- Dustin she'll do it.
Dustin put the email back.
- You should do that.
- There's still a spelling error.
- You fucked up again?
You can't spell for shit Dustin.
- No.
- It's okay Dustin,
you can find me
you can DM me on Instagram too.
I have my handles up
there all three of them.
Okay I mean I obviously
have a little extra time now
- Sure Melissa can you
check your email real quick,
and see if anyone has emailed you?
- Yeah Dustin...
- Oh you're in.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- Can you check it real quick?
How many people are gonna
surely buy this thing
for 72 to 99 dollars.
I'm think about raising it to 99 dollars.
- Seriously.
- It's a club.
You're paying for the club,
and then you're getting the bars.
- What else should the club offer?
- Access.
(both talking over each other)
- Just for people who might do this.
- You'll build a company.
Just like that nice kid Kris earlier
with the nonprofit.
At first you'll be like,
"Hey guys we're here
to fucking Gary, right weird. "
And you're gonna get comfortable,
you get to know each other.
And then then it gets rolling,
then you're doing Y night.
then you're fucking make a T-shirt.
- I'm into fitness too,
which is kind where
this protein came about.
- You'll do a workout regimen,
it's gonna work.
- I have two emails by a bunch people
are following me on Instagram.
- Two is better than zero,
and everybody's watching right now.
So as soon as this ends,
everyone's gonna actually email you.
But I really really
really think that this...
- Well what if I could bring
like fitness people on,
or do cooking class I mean I could make it
I could just create a
whole series of music...
- Melissa I'm telling you right now.
People are gonna pay $99 for the bar.
I think the way you do it
is you do it by monthly,
so they just sign up for the subscription.
Basically they're paying $600
a year to be in the club.
Every buy month they get the $99 bucks
for you know with 12 bars.
They can reorder more ad hoc,
if they'd like because
maybe some of the people
like, "This bar better
than by other bars."
Like I think it's very real.
- If this comes true,
you literally just like
made my dreams come true.
- Melissa I have something better for you
this is a hundred percent gonna come true.
I'm desperately hoping it happens for you.
But right now there are hundreds of people
deciding to use this business model.
This is actually a business model.
This is a big model like
somebody with peanut butter,
somebody with T-shirts,
somebody with music.
Like people are gonna do this.
I'm completely convinced.
- Well I mean maybe we
should just build it
as a business model,
and that's like another step.
- Keep your ambitions down.
Let's be practical here.
This is where people get fucked
oh we're gonna build a fucking platform.
- No no yeah yeah yeah I'm an executor,
I promise you.
- I believe you.
I like your energy.
I can feel it.
Listen to that ninety nine bucks a month.
Real quick.
Listen I want to know from
everybody in the community
that it literally apply I'm in,
if you're actually gonna sign up
for the $99 protein community bar.
I want to see in if you're in.
I'm really curious.
- If they'll say I'm in right now.
Then I'm going to register it.
- Dustin.
Dustin is gonna start showing
you all the ones right now.
- Then I'm going to
manufacturing tomorrow.
I'm gonna turn it.
- Here's better this..
This is such a great community,
take the money from everybody on presale.
I'm telling you right now,
like Susan Barnes is in.
- Thank you Susan.
- MeraLord is in.
(Melissa laughs)
Melissa this is gonna work.
I'm telling you.
Frostytv is in.
Vedox is in.
- This is amazing.
- Alejandro is in.
- This is awesome.
- It's gonna work.
And now you have framework,
now you can promote.
- Yeah I mean you're
literally changing my life,
and making something I
dream about come true.
I didn't think about it this way.
- Because what I'm creative in
like what I'm good at is seeing things
that other people don't.
I think that's what I'm good at,
that's why I innovate.
Wine text
by the way.
- Oh you're in Michigan.
You're fine you're fine.
- I do buy empathy and send it
to everyone for Christmas
gifts just so you know.
- I love you.
- I love you too.
- Can you please post wine
text in Facebook page,
and be like oh my wines like
you know everyone's drinking wine.
- Especially right now.
- Shits blowing up.
- Shit is blowing up you
know what else is blowing up?
It fits bar is blowing up
the $99 bimonthly community,
that happens to sell protein bars.
- I appreciate you.
They're vegan and gluten-free people,
but they taste delicious.
- But here's the best part,
you're gonna build a community.
And people are gonna get these bars,
they're gonna start passing out the bars,
so many people gonna value
the $600 for the community.
Cause you're fucking
your energy is on point.
This is why I'm giving you this idea,
you're very good at it.
I think you're gonna be good at it.
I think a lot of people
that have been on the show
wouldn't be good at being the
Pied Piper of the community.
If did this I'd fucking make
40 trillion a year on it.
- I know (laughs).
I want to do thank you for this advice.
I mean 40 trillion would be amazing.
- You know what's good like for example,
like somebody said it's too expensive,
and and I understand that from
the Breanna physical because she's looking
at the literal execution a
bar should be not $6 or $3.
I get it.
And by the way to her point
she might jump on here,
and say and there's other
communities that's great.
But it's gonna your community.
- Yeah yeah yeah like
my community for sure.
And Gary is gonna come to one of this...
- Relax Melissa.
I like the salesmanship.
- I'm a terrible salesman (laughs).
- No you're a great salesman.
That was a fucking great pitch.
That was a super gangster shit.
- So everyone's gonna be like I'm in.
That's that's awesome.
I really really appreciate it.
One last question and
this is totally unrelated.
Were you sore after the plank challenge?
- I kind of did that downward dog
like once she told me we could do
I didn't realize you could
do like on your hands,
I was always like this.
Not not terribly I'm super sore today,
because I did fucking Bulgarian
split squats yesterday.
Which are the fucking worst.
- Yeah they're I agree.
I fully agree.
- I fucking hate that shit.
I did ABS this morning which is super fun.
I'm starting to actually like I...
I never eaten this five and a half years
that I finally got my health together,
I never like abs are a
byproduct of everything
else something but I've
never gone ham on abs.
I'm a little chunky right now,
because of COVID,
a lot of men.
Like mine goes a little bit to the tummy,
but like I'm really excited
about building up my
like building a ab muscles
has been really excruciating
especially because of my back issues.
We're really on that
kick right now with Mike,
which has been fun.
- Awesome. Gary I appreciate
you thank you so much.
- Let's put up your email one last time.
Let's put up Melissa's email.
- Listen everybody I really
want you to try to do this.
I'll give you guys...
First several of you you
should do this for a reason.
You also have product ideas,
and I think doing a year with Melissa.
And watching how she does it.
Stumbling through it will help
you launch your peanut butter,
your flowers, your T-shirts,
your coffee version of this.
I think there's a huge business model.
I think I will recall
this video in seven years,
when this is a common business model,
and I'll be like you know
told you.
- And I'll be like Gary changed my life.
Thank you Gary.
- You're welcome bye-bye
- Bye.
- Dustin.
- Yes sir.
- Super high end Pinot
Noir today you know,
and I know yesterday's Cabernet
sold out in like 12 minutes.
So a lot of people looking
for Father's Day gifts,
didn't work out,
but today's is like a 48 dollar wine.
I think it's gonna go for 22 bucks.
Pinot which is like
the hot grape varietal.
I think it's pretty good stuff.
Dustin why are people that
are watching right now,
why have they not signed up for wine text?
When they actually buy wine.
Obviously real quick yesterday,
I did the whole joke
about like will block you,
if you've signed up for wine text,
and you don't buy whine.
Please on today's offer hit stop,
or unsubscribe or whatever.
The functionality is because
it costs money to send texts.
So you're being very sweet,
but I don't want you on the list,
if you're not a wine buyer.
- What if you buying
for corporate reasons.
- Yeah.
If you're buying for corporate reasons,
or if you're a real estate agent.
Like what I love about wine
text it's a great b2b thing,
because yesterday we sold
a hundred dollar wine
for $39 when you give
that wine to your boss,
or a client and they google it at $109,
you get that clout.
But your cost is low that's...
What's great about wine
text is these prices
are insanely on like...
I don't know if you know
I've been telling you off-screen
like they're crazy deals.
I'm really excited about it.
Please sign up for wine
texts if you have it.
I'm just gonna read the comments here,
somebody signed up yesterday.
I know a lot of people
or I know Texas and I know
there's a lot of place
you can't ship to.
Yes you can just send a gift to US.
I would sign up for three
phones if I wasn't in.
I could not tell you were
joking yesterday (laughs).
It's funny.
I am good sometimes.
Gabriel cos thank you.
- Some people DM yes.
Telling me that please don't ban me.
(both laugh)
- I would never do that,
but I am excited about wine text.
And if nothing else because we
can't ship to certain states,
because of their own shipping laws.
Gabi Ramos winetext.com is a service
I created for my dad's wine shop.
It's a deal of the day,
crazy deal of the day.
Each day that comes in text form.
When you sign up you
put your credit card in,
so all you have to do
when you get the text
is hit reply with a number
of bottles you want,
and then we send it to you.
It's been huge Massachusetts you're in,
you can do it please go to
wine text if you have it.
And if you're in
South Carolina you're good.
Please go to the site don't ask.
Ohio you're good (laughs).
I know you're asking, please go to site,
you'll see the states that
we can or can't ship to.
But it would really mean the world to me
if you're a wine
drinker.
What's a little Lou doing?
- He said eh (laughs).
- Eh what.
Eh he's like sad that he lost his job now.
(Dustin laughs)
Sign up but more importantly a lot of you
could really do this for me.
It would really matter
to me if you could post
it on either Twitter or your Facebook.
I mean Facebook post
is a monster you know,
like somebody just posting
like best wine deals.
And I'm like we're getting
like 1 or 2 signups
from each one of those,
even when people have just
20 or 30 or 40 friends.
Because it's a cosign to your community.
So it would really really
really matter to me,
if you could do that.
I think Kansas is good
John please sign up.
But again don't sign up if
you're not a wine buyer,
because it cost money
but the deals are sick.
Today's like $48 Pinot for like 22 bucks,
like we've got a white wine I
just put the final touches on.
It'll be a month from now
but its $38 Chardonnay,
we're gonna sell it for $9 Dustin.
- It's a good deal (laughs).
- Sign up for my new Twitter account,
here are the details.
And the people that are gonna win
over the next five to seven years
are gonna be very comfortable
in controlled fucking chaos.
You don't want the process.
This is the dream you're talking about.
Dream rules require sacrifices.
Full new actions have to then map to it.
(imitates phone ringing)
back back back back back.
Nobody gives a shit
about where you grew up.
The whole game is scaling the unscalable.
It's fucking hard work,
it's being respectful,
it's being a good person.
Do that that's just a good idea.
It's there the flip things there.
This house right here is $400.
I stand corrected,
like real fucking tight.
But you can't be crippled,
everybody here judging themselves.
You're looking at what's
in front of you right now.
You're losing cause
you're laying in your bed
looking at somebody's fucking
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool,
and you're envious and you're jealous,
and you're impatient and
it's crippling your up side.
Let me just say it one more time,
if you're confused what I just said.
I say put your fucking flag on the ground,
up who the fuck you are.
Whoever provides the
most value always wins.
You're entering the greatest
five year window of your life.
My only answer today or any much like
it's just like try shit.
Shut your business down and go work
for an apparel company pretenders.
Nobody you've ever met got
there without the hard work.
So you better get your speed up,
you better work harder,
you better work smarter.
(upbeat music)
If you can't Google stuff,
you're not gonna be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
GARYVEETV.
like me at.
Check me out hope you enjoy it.
(music ends)